لقد مرت الساعة الخامسة للتو هنا في الدوحة
، والحركة التي تجري خلفنا في استاد خليفة
ما زالت جارية ، حيث من
المقرر تحديد ست ميداليات ذهبية هذا
المساء ، ولكن كما ترون ، لا
يتدفق الناس بالضبط عند البوابات الدوارة
وهذا ليس  هذه هي بطولة العالم في أي حدث ،
لذا فإن الصور التي
تم بثها حول العالم
لبعض من أعظم الرياضيين في كل
العصور يحتفلون
بإنجازاتهم المذهلة أمام منصات شبه فارغة
قد أثارت بعض
الأسئلة الجادة للمنظمين والهيئة الحاكمة لألعاب القوى
العالمية  بطولة العالم هذه في الخامس
من مايو ولا توجد
مقارنة ، إنها أقل نسبة جمهور على
الإطلاق والشيء الأول هو أن
أقل جمهور على الإطلاق هو أن
الجمهور الموجود في الملعب لا
يفهم ألعاب القوى ،
أصدرت اللجنة المنظمة المحلية
بيانًا  معالجة المشكلة مع الاعتراف بأن
الأرقام كانت أقل من
توقعاتهم وهذه الاقتباسات نحن واثقون من أن
جهودنا المتجددة ستنجح  شجع المجتمع المحلي
على القدوم
ومشاهدة الأداء المذهل لأفضل
الرياضيين في العالم وبعد حوالي 90 دقيقة
من بدء الحدث داخل الاستاد في
اليوم الرابع ، كان هناك تدفق مفاجئ جيدًا
بعد ثلاثة أيام من الانتقادات
للعديد من المقاعد الفارغة هنا في  تلقت الدوحة
جواباً على المشكلة
، تم نقل المئات والمئات والمئات من
الرجال إلى هنا لمشاهدة ما حدث هذا
المساء ، قال أحد الأطفال الذين تحدثت إليهم
إنه اكتشف فقط أنه سيأتي
بعد ظهر اليوم ، رد الاتحاد الدولي للمرأة على
سؤالنا حول من  كانت المجموعات
تقول كما هو الحال مع العديد من منظمي الأحداث الرياضية الكبيرة
توفير الترتيبات لمجموعات المجتمع
للوصول إلى الحدث وهناك
أيضًا مجموعات مدرسية موجودة هنا من خلال
برنامج المدرسة ، لذا فهي
أكثر انشغالًا بشكل هامشي مما رأيناه في الداخل ولكن
بالتأكيد ليست قريبة من أي مكان.
وهي بالتأكيد ليست مجموعات
الرجال الذين يرتدون قمصانهم المتطابقة
هي الأجواء بدلاً من ذلك كما رأينا
في اليومين الماضيين ، هناك
زاوية واحدة  على وجه الخصوص مع بعض
الجيوب الكبيرة من الإثيوبيين والكينيين
الذين يعيشون هنا لدعم رياضييهم ،
الدوحة ليست مكانًا جديدًا لألعاب
القوى ، لقد أتت إلى هنا ولكن ملعبين أصغر
منذ أكثر من عشر سنوات ، لكن هذا
هو أكبر حدث رياضي دولي كبير
يقام هنا منذ ذلك الحين  تحول الانتباه
في اتجاهه مع انطلاق بطولة
كأس العالم لكرة القدم الآن بعد ثلاث سنوات فقط ،
ومن المؤكد أنها ليست الصورة
التي أرادت ألعاب القوى أو قطر أن
يراها العالم أماندا ديفيس سي إن إن الدوحة قطر